so you but you say you were a little bit
more blue pilled was there was there a
moment for you where you were like oh
wait a minute uh I think it was when I
was on the show and I could just
oh after you started the content
um I would say there's there no okay
because it's hard because different
things I changed like opinions on I've
always been more conservative and I will
say conservative like lines up with a
lot of this stuff but when I think of
cheating
okay when I was explaining to girls that
like that top guys in society will cheat
I understand like the men explaining
things to me before because you'd be
like well but my dad and like and I'm
like we're not talking about you Rebecca
there's actually no girl named Rebecca
but